cómo vamos a resolver esto exactamente
dividamos las fichas en partes iguales y
ya pensemos lo de esta forma la
siguiente vez que lanzar la moneda tengo
el 50% de probabilidad de ganar espera
voy a necesitar dibujarlo dibujarlo
dibujando como un árbol bien entonces la
próxima vez bueno de cara o cruz
si cada cruz exacto se cae cara salgan
si cae cara gana salga no las 8 si te
quedas con el montón completo pero si es
cruz pero si es cruz seguimos jugando
entonces déjame dibujar otra
ramificación como está bien de nuevo
será cara o cruz ahora en este punto se
sale cara ganó salgan salgan y si es
cruz tu ganas si sale cruz gana brit
veces hay posibilidad de que gane por
eso me corresponde la mitad de las
fichas existe posibilidad de que ganes
pero la probabilidad no es la mitad la
probabilidad de que cannes es
sustancialmente menor que la mitad
existe una probabilidad de un medio que
esto suceda esta rama tiene una
probabilidad de un medio y esta otra
tiene una probabilidad de un medio y si
tuviéramos que lanzarla una segunda vez
entonces cada uno de estos resultados
tiene una probabilidad de un medio así
que para obtener dos cruces consecutivas
tienes una probabilidad de un medio por
un medio es decir sólo un cuarto de
probabilidad de que esto ocurra también
hay sólo un cuarto de probabilidad de
que salga primero cruz y después otra
cara así que tengo un medio más un
cuarto de probabilidades de ganar un
medio más un cuarto es lo mismo que dos
cuartos más un cuarto tengo tres cuartos
de probabilidad de ganar así que dame
tres cuartos de estas fichas y pero
tenemos ocho fichas aquí sí sí pero
podemos pensarlo de esta forma tengo un
medio de probabilidad de ganar en el
siguiente es decir cuatro fichas de ese
y después si no gano en el segundo
entonces sigo teniendo uno
de probabilidad de ganarlo por lo tanto
debería quedarme con seis fichas que es
tres cuartos de ocho y yo solo me quedo
con dos desafortunadamente para ti ese
sería el caso sabes que quiero la mitad
de las fichas pero no puedo argumentar
contra esto no puedes argumentar contra
la lógica perfecta jaja